welcome back well days after a truce
with Hamas collapse Israeli forces have
turned their focus to Southern Gaza
hitting areas where hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians have sought
shelter since the start of the war
turkey's president erdogan today
denounced Benjamin Netanyahu as a
butcher and said he would eventually be
tried as a war criminal we're joining me
now from Tel Aviv as a prime minister
senior adviser Mark regf Mr Reg thank
you very much indeed for joining me
again your reaction first of all my
pleasure you're action first of all to
president erdogan he said that of the
Prime Minister Beyond being a war
criminal Netanyahu is the Butcher of
Gaza right now will be tried as the
Butcher of Gaza just as mosovich was
tried what is your reaction to
that I of course don't accept the
criticism and unfortunately this is not
out of uh out of a a character for for
the Turkish leadership which has of
course been very critical over the years
of of Israel and very supportive I
should say of
Hamas the big question now now is
exactly what is the game plan for Israel
you're moving into the South there are
as we know 2 million Palestinians now
crowded into a 90 square mile area um
this is already clearly I would say
indisputably a humanitarian crisis there
but also they were told to go south to
be safe now they're being attacked in
the South nowhere is safe now in Gaza
would you accept
that no when we when we told people to
relocate to the South it was true the
the fighting was concentrating in the
north and we asked people to move to the
South because they'd be safer and that
was true then now the operation is
continuing into areas of the South and
we've specified as has been widely
reported specific areas in the South
which remain safer zones and we've urged
people to relocate there now we know
it's difficult to move uh my father was
a refugee he had to move from place to
place in the second world War to to save
his life I know it's difficult to move
but surely it's better to move than it
is to stay in a combat zone and get
caught up in crossfire it's all a matter
of managing risk we want to see
civilians outside combat zones we don't
want to see them accidentally hurt it's
best for them to move and the truth is
we're seeing now gazin are voting with
their feet and are moving to the areas
which we've specified as safer areas but
eventually this operation is going to
clearly lead to you attacking all over
Gaza where do they eventually move all
these people is the operation actually
designed to permanently displace the
Palestinian people as some
fear no not at all and we hope that
people can when the fighting is over
that people can go back to their homes
and where homes have been destroyed
because of the fighting there'll be
temporary shelters for them I hope but
but it is common sense our enemy is
Hamas and as you know Hamas is embedded
itself in civilian neighborhoods in
mosques in schools uh in hospitals
unfortunately and and we've had to fight
Kamas and we will defeat Kamas but once
Kamas is defeated of course we'll be
allowing people to return to their homes
and of course there'll be a massive
rebuilding reconstruction campaign of
Gaza that's going to be needed how many
terrorists have you
killed so I can't give you an exact
amount because the war is still going on
but we we see the the death hole in in
in fatalities on the terrorist side in
the thousands but if you don't know how
do you know if you know what I mean well
we've got we've got estimates but
because we're not sure and I'll explain
to you why we're not sure you you blow
up an underground bunker yes which Kamas
has got these Underground fortifications
Across the gas strip you destroy it you
don't necessarily know if there were 10
terrorists inside or 20 or 50 yes
because you've destroyed an un
underground fortification so it's all
based on approximations when this is
over I think we'll have a more precise
understanding of the numbers but I've
been in briefings and I I've heard the
numbers it's in the thousand
right I mean I hear this from the
Israeli side but nobody seems to be able
to produce any concrete evidence and I
understand slightly the fog of War but
the significance of this is that if you
can't actually produce hard evidence of
how many Hamas terrorists you you're
killing and the death toll of innocent
civilians keeps rising and rising and
Rising as it has done now over
15,000 by the Hamas run Health
authorities estimation you know you know
the public appr probium that coming
Israel's way the longer this goes on
isn't it incumbent on Israel to actually
be able to produce clear evidence of the
volume of Hamas terrorists you're
killing because if there are 35,000 of
them and you've only killed a thousand
or 2,000 so far then the fear is that
the civilian death toll is going to be a
100,000 200,000 before you can even
think about eradicating Hamas what is
the the line for Israel is there one or
is there no limit on civilian casualties
so long as you still got Hamas terrorist
to
kill so first of all we don't want to
see a single civilian casualty you've
heard me say that before and we mean it
we don't want to see civilians caught up
in the cross FR that's why we're urging
people to leave combat zones it's common
sense if we don't want to see them get
caught up in the fighting between the
Israeli Defense Forces and Kamas please
we urge people to leave combat zones and
most of the the civilians do so Hamas as
you know and has been reported
they've urged people to stay ordered
people to stay even at gunpoint because
they want those guys and civilians as a
human shield but white right-minded
person agrees to be a human shield foras
of course they want to leave and we have
to facilitate their leave and even now
as as we move towards our ground
incursion in the South I can assure you
that Escape Routes will be there for the
civilians to still reach the safe areas
because we don't want to see them come
into Harm's Way and we'll make every
effort possible about the numbers and
you ask a good question uh
look we could just articulate numbers
the way Kamas does and just make them up
and and throw them out there no we're
very precise and if we don't have a
precise number we're not going to make
one up when you say when I say in the
thousands I know what I'm talking about
it's more than 2,000 it's in the
thousands uh but we don't want to say
numbers that we're not 100% sure but I
can say something that we are sure of uh
look we're fighting a difficult war
against a brutal terrorist organization
in in an urban area and we if we compare
ourselves to let's say what what the
West did against Isis in places like
mosul and and and fua I am sure when
this is over and you can have me back if
this is not true but I am sure because I
know this to be the the case when one
looks at the the what what they the
experts call the the combat to civilian
death Rao yes and you will compare the
idf's behavior in Gaza together with
against what the West did in let's say
places like MOS and fua I think the IDF
is going to come out very favorably how
favorably will Israel come out with
what's going on with the settlers is on
the West Bank I watched a very
disturbing report on the BBC from Jeremy
Bowen tonight where there is clear huge
aggression from Israeli settlers against
Palestinians a lot of deaths and Hamas
are not involved there they're not the
controlling body how do you feel about
that so first of all we did have a
terrible terrorist attack in Jerusalem
just a few days ago where Kamas shot at
people waiting at a bus stop on their
way to work I think that was was that
Friday morning or Thursday morning last
week that was widely reported
Hamas doesn't control the West Bank but
Hamas has violent cells across the West
Bank that are there and they've wanted
to activate those cells and that's why
we we had those murderous attacks in
Jerusalem just a few days ago Kamas is
there they're more Underground on the
West Bank but there's still a threat and
we've tried to be as proactive as we can
be in trying to go out there and arrest
Kamas activist look Kamas in gazra is
under a lot of pressure so they've sent
messages to all their C in the West Bank
this is a time for you guys to kill Jews
yes and and they succeeded unfortunately
last week but we have limited their
ability to to kill people by being
proactive arresting people in the middle
of the night does wiping outes wiping
out
Villages um and looking like you are
encroaching more and more with the
settlements throughout this conflict is
that not just incredibly inflammatory uh
to the Palestinian people living in the
West
Bank appears there's been no Villages
that have been wiped out I literally saw
one on thec where where it's been almost
demolished and the people have been
displaced 200 or so had been displaced
permanently so so once again I'm not
sure what you're talking about and I
apologize for not having that
information but the Israeli policy on
the West Bank is to Live and Let Live
yes and Palestinians are not with
respect that's not that's not what's
beenen I disagree I mean it's obviously
been a difficult period but we have so
far managed to keep and despite the
fatalities we had last week yes it could
be a lot worse but through our actions
we've managed to keep the level of
violence on the West Bank relatively low
I mean the Kamas people want to see an
explosion on the West Bank that's what
they want they want to see Hamas
activists get on the on on on Jeeps like
they did in Gaza and come into Jewish
communities and butcher people that's
what they want to see and so far once
again we had fatalities last week but I
think overall we've managed to keep the
level of violence relatively low and
that's a good thing for Israelis and
palestin final question what is Victory
going to look like here I mean if there
are still Hamas terrorists alive the end
of this is that Victory or do they
simply buy their time regroup and come
back at Israel even stronger because so
many people would have been killed by
then in
Gaza so when Victory is the destruction
of hamas's military machine and the end
of their political control over the Gaza
Strip a bit like victory over Isis in
Iraq and Syria you didn't have to kill
every last Isis gunman but you destroyed
their territorial Independence you
destroyed their ability to to control an
enclave because that gives them power we
can't destroy the Kamas idea just as you
can't destroy the Isis idea but you can
remove from them the capability to
inflict pain on others and and we
believe that once we have destroyed
hamas's Terror regime in Gaza there will
be room to build something uh better for
the Palestinians they can build it
themselves we'll support them uh but
let's be clear here when this is over
hamas's path of extremism of radicalism
of violence of Terror will be
discredited not because it hurt us but
because it hurt the people of Gaza I
mean the people of Gaza are not stupid
they can see who started this war who
brought all this destruction upon them
who even ended the ceasefire by refusing
to to release more hostages the people
of Gaza know this they can't speak their
minds today because they live in a
terrible dictatorial State Hamas does
not allow people to criticize them and
and not face consequences violent
consequences but when this is over and
the people of Gaza can speak they will
say that Hamas brought this tragedy upon
them and there'll be room I think to
work with Palestinian moderates to build
a better future for Gaza it's good for
Israel it's good for gazans Mr thank you
very much one question for you uh I
would love to interview prime minister
Netanyahu I interviewed him back in
March when he was in London I've put in
a number of requests he's not spoken yet
to any European media entity only
American once could we have an interview
with Prim Minister
net so so I'll I'll check that out with
the Prime Minister I know he's
interviewed in the past and he's enjoyed
that he could well do it again I just
can't commit for him at the moment H he
has been focused on American Media I
think we've done I think 95% of our
interviews have beened to the US market
because the US market the Americans are
our most important Ally as you well
understand well Britain has proven to be
a pretty good Ally too so that's why I'm
asking the question I think it might be
you 100% correct Britain Britain has
been a good Ally in this in this
conflict and so has Germany and we know
to appreciate our friends well it would
be good it would be good to be interview
the Prime Minister if he could spare the
time you can pass that message to him I
will speak to him about it the next time
I see him thank you very much appreciate
it Mr Reger thank
you